[Music]
washington-dc gets blown up all the time
in the movies but what if it happened
for real hopefully we'll never find out
but federal emergency officials have to
prepare for the worst emergency
responders would have to deal with
shattered buildings rubble filled
streets downed power lines fried cell
phones radioactive contamination and
casualties numbering in the hundreds of
thousands it would be a disaster beyond
anything ever seen in an American city
certainly beyond anything that emergency
managers have ever experienced so to
help them figure out what to expect in
such a catastrophe
researchers from Virginia Tech
University built an entire digital DC
inside a computer and have blown it up
over and over and over in an effort to
make their model as accurate as possible
to start with the basic geography of
Washington and then they add in every
building every road every power line
every hospital even every cell tower
next the modelers populate their virtual
deceive millions of digital people known
as agents these agents are like members
of the crowd and a computer-generated
scene in a movie they can move around
the landscape and react to each other
and their surroundings in human-like
ways but unlike CGI crowds each agent
pursues its own goals they can switch
between goals like run hide help out and
find loved ones finally the modelers
simulate the effects of a ten kiloton
nuclear bomb that explodes on a Monday
morning in May just a few blocks north
of the White House they use standard
models of blast effects estimate
casualties and damage to buildings they
use weather models to track the spread
of fallout
but they allow the agents to react to
the disaster as individuals
this gives the agents bottom of behavior
the kind of spontaneity that's so often
seen in real life and that's almost
impossible to model in any other way
it also gives emergency managers a much
better handle on the surprising and
obstinate ways that people often behave
in a crisis for example if the
authorities warned everyone to find
shelter and stay there into the fallout
dies down the model shows that many
people will ignore them instead they'll
be out on the roads desperately trying
to pick up their kids from school or
find missing spouses many of them may
even end up travelling toward ground
zero but the model also shows that the
authorities can minimize this chaos they
move quickly to restore cell service if
people can verify that their loved ones
are safe they're more likely to stay
where they are
this Disaster Response simulation is
just one example of what agent based
models can do more and more real-world
decision makers are using these models
to plan new highways improve the flow of
crowds in public places plan how to
respond to epidemics or even minimize
the chances of a stock market crash
[Music]
[Music]